sometimes you do some crazy [ __ ] you
were in a motorcycle accident not too
long i got a lot
that's my point i mean i say if i was
george clooney i wouldn't leave the
house i don't want anything to happen to
my face
i'm have too good a life you're on a
crazy [ __ ] motorcycle
i mean that what did you do how did you
skid it out
no i was it was in sardinia and i was
going about 70 miles an hour and a guy
turned in front of me and i was launched
i i was
it does all those things you see in the
you know on the street after an accident
knocked me out of my shoes my shoes were
all the way down the street and uh
i landed on my hands and knees i mean if
you threw a pencil up in the air
you know a thousand times like landed on
my hands and knees if i'd landed any
other way it probably would have killed
me and
i you know i used up my nine lives on
that one and
you know i was in the hospital and a
mall came and got me in a very
vulnerable position i'll say
and said okay that's it with motorcycles
and i was like okay
no i mean i mean i've talked to billy
joel about that he loves motorcycles i
still don't know
he said after he had a crash terrible
people walked up and go
hey look it's billy joel's blood and do
people do that when you have an accident
do they go
hey george clooney that was the most
amazing thing you know i'm
i'm a pretty optimistic guy and i kind
of i do i do
i believe i believe in the goodness of
people i think that things in general
work out and but i will say there's a
moment
that moment you know when you um when i
hit the ground
and i really thought i'm waiting for
like the switch to click off i thought
this was it i'd broken this windshield
in
my i thought all my teeth were knocked
out it was glass from the windshield was
in my mouth
i was bleeding a lot and i was sitting
there i was really screaming
and everybody got out and they just
pulled out their cameras and started
taking pictures and saying oh
and i'll remember that for a long time
because i thought
there's that moment where you just it's
like when somebody falls in the subway
now and everybody pulls their phone out
and you go go
get them out of the subway you know yeah
they're trying to live their lives
through a phone now
imagine i'm driving along and then i go
hey wait a second george clooney's head
just came through my windshield how cool
is that
you